hey my long time alright so after Jeff
Blake's anti-trump speech the press
responded just how you'd expect as
impeachment sheep if he is dangerous to
democracy as you say
should he be removed from office well
there is a way that Congress can change
this do you think Congress should be
pursuing every avenue to get President
Trump out of office senator is there a
difference in your mind between a
president who and these are your words
undermines our democratic ideals and has
a flagrant disregard for the truth and
decency and the president who is unfit
to hold the office our words enough
though is senator what should you and
your colleagues be doing it's positively
Pavlovian but you can't blame the media
for asking that question
flake pretty much demanded a revolt
against Trump yet when asked flake
flakes I don't think any of those
remedies are justified no I don't I
don't want to go down that road I don't
think some of the remedies that are
being talked about impeachment high
crimes and just misdemeanors I don't
think that that applies
that's backtracking so why start what
you can't finish maybe because it was
baloney to begin with because if flake
really thought democracy was under
attack why wouldn't he stay in fight
imagine if Hillary were in office would
a Republican senator say she's harming
our country therefore I'm retiring
doesn't make any sense
Trump may not be your choice but flakes
exit seems more about losing a future
election than feuding with the president
his speech was high drama that gets
Pat's on the head from his cool new
friends in the media flake basically
went for a short term sugar high sure
that deep-fried Twinkie is initially
pleasing at the street fair but you'll
regret it and you saw that in flakes
exit interviews so like a poodle
he took his moment to get his back
scratched by the Dems
and a belly rub from the media the
validation a nice doggie treat but it
was cheap and it was damaging to his
body and the body politic yet as he
bails he still claims the high ground
now if you're leaving because you know
you can't win just go quietly
this stand isn't brave its petulance
scorched-earth bravado as you go to your
room and slam the door
now opposing Donald Trump it's a real
option for anyone in honest government
but hidden run guerrilla tactics only
work when you stay in the battle this is
the teacher's pet who sticks his tongue
out at you that hides behind the teacher
it's the courage of a spectator true
there's been nothing like Donald Trump
in tone or tenor among Republicans but
there's always been rough rhetoric from
the left this is new turf for us too bad
Jeff late that was a play on words
Kimberly I can never tell when you're
happy or sad it's why we have issues so
this guy Jeff Flake if it's his real
name I'm not sure he essentially said
the enemy to democracy is Trump so why
wouldn't the media say impeach it made
absolutely no sense because I mean okay
listen what's he gonna say about this
cuz he's backing down come out with some
great statement as to why it is that
you're moving on you're not gonna seek
reelection and instead he does this
whole thing really shames himself by
saying if you think there's something
wrong and you don't speak up then you're
complicit in your part of the problem
right so he's not only going to just
like slip away into the night he had a
chance to say something he said that and
he's leaving yeah makes no sense not a
good career move
wasn't inspirational Jesse I want to
play this so this is from a show called
Morning Joe I've never heard of it
tell me more about it well I think it's
a radical great ban but on there Jeff
Flake was on there and he had to say
this the bottom line is if I were to run
a campaign that I could be proud of
and where I didn't have to cozy up to
the president and his positions or his
behavior I could not win in a Republican
primary
that's the bottom line it's it's it's
not that you have to just be with the
President on policy you can't question
his behavior and still be a Republican
in good standing apparently in a
Republican primary do you think he's
he's honest in the sense that he
couldn't win yeah but is he being
dishonest by saying you
can't question Trump didn't one of the
people that Tom Trump backed lose just
recently in a primary yeah you saw the
writing on the wall and he hailed and
that was the most honest thing I think
he said the entire little apology tour
whatever you want to call it if you're a
Republican in DC the fastest way to
media stardom is to attack another
Republican exactly John McCain but they
get used and abuse I mean he's just
another little item on the assembly line
that the media comes picks up and throws
at the president they've been wanting to
impeach this guy from the jump first it
was about collusion then it was a bit
obstruction then he was mentally unfit
and now they just don't like his
character right so they want him to get
out of there the line of questioning
shows their hand remember Scott
McClellan mm-hmm press secretary for w
and total trader went out wrote a hit
piece book did the media book tour then
was totally discarded had no friends on
the Left had no friends on the right
same things happening to flake he's the
flavor of the month but if Ted Cruz came
out he'd they'd do the same thing he'd
be on every single Sunday show all these
people in the green room hey Ted you
know lying Ted that was really mean
really wish you won the primary it's
total phony Ennis and again that was the
smartest thing I think flake said he was
going down he knew he's gonna get smoked
it's a strange new respect award the
American Spectator came up with that
like if you agree with your adversaries
yeah they will then I'll become your
friend one can i play this is Donald
Trump responding to Jeff Flake we have
that on tape for you at home his poll
numbers in Arizona are so low that he
couldn't win
I don't blame her for leaving I think he
did the right thing for himself the
first time I saw him in television I had
not really been nobody knew me in terms
of politics but the first time I saw him
in television I said I assume he's a
Democrat he's been terribly for the
great people of Arizona state that likes
Donald Trump very much as you even you
will admit and he would have never won
so he did the smart thing for himself
this way he can get out somewhat
gracefully you know why why wouldn't you
could respond to that but also why
wouldn't Jeff Flake run as an
independent or something like that run
as a Democrat
I don't think that he would be welcome
to the Democratic Party you know Jeff
Flake it for those of you having to
follow him is a real principled
conservative who voted with Donald Trump
I think they say 90 percent of the time
right but he is discomforted by Trump's
behavior Trump's anger and I think and
this is the point I'd make to you Greg
he feels at the moment the Republican
Party has become I think I'm using his
language here the party of anger
resentment and grievance rather than the
party of Prince if we learned that from
the dams well I don't know you could you
always like to throw back at the dentist
but I think that there is such a fight
going on among Republicans at this
moment that it's very interesting is the
Republican Party the party of Trump do
you just have to be loyal to Trump and
it's like a cult of personality or can
you hold to what was previously
conservative principle in terms of free
markets low taxes Pro immigration I like
you know there's a lot Dana in under
President Obama another cult of
personality there were there were
conservative Democrats that still
remained as Democrats even though they
disagreed perhaps with a lot of what
President Obama do even if you go back
to Bill Clinton and during all of that
stuff the Democrats pretty much all hung
together but everything's different yes
like the whole thing parties evolved and
they change and I I think that if you
watch what President Trump did today
asked several times he actually didn't
really take the bait to counterpunch
even more to keep this thing going he
said he made the right decision for
himself I think that way he can exit
gracefully and I don't
I feel like even President Trump and
Sarah Sanders did this last week they
basically let it go and I think if they
want to be continued to be more
successful about not just uniting a
party but getting people to accept
ignoring the words and just looking at
what he does
then they have to also I think that
they've realized this maybe except that
the disposition of the president is
uncomfortable for some people and they
have to let him say that as long as then
they are looking at what they do and not
just what they say I mean half there
seems to be no give right okay and I
think that's what he was saying but also
how many people do you know that you
work with over the years that complain
every day about their job right why
don't you leave then why don't you quit
actually what wait
he decided like May I think that I would
have declined the additional many
opportunities I think I would have let
the speech stand and just basically sit
alone at the lunch table for the next
year and a half yeah and not do the rest
of the media interviews because I agree
that you're supposed to be a nice person
and now I have to defend Greg Gutfeld
your health conditions you're in order
to make this place a better place you
know people that are like that though
you think well why don't you get a new
job and might you see you know some
people that send crazy reply-all emails
oh that's at me is that me how soon do
you think flake is gonna be an MSNBC
contributor contributor I think he's
gonna go back to Arizona and be a think
tank guy think tank I mean I don't know
that those think tank guy there's a
weird superhero think tank guy that's a
really boring costume all right